you I must be too close to my arms bent
so that that that's good because if you
then start getting so that when you
become comfortable you're about stop
thinking about yourself and you're about
perhaps open your mind to go
wider
so you we should all know that oeni said
two people must become one don't we know
that or two people must become one so
how can I become one with
Peter do we get you know do we get in a
movement of a Ry turning and that is
that two people become one yes it
is but if I am
Peter so if I am Peter and he I am
Peter to1 there's no tone on that
movement there was no tone there was
only Peter cuz he moved me so that's you
know that takes a bit of getting your
head real does it see I smokes a lot of
that weed oh that must the
film
no what I was very nervous about
teaching today because I've never taught
this way before but I wanted to part
with this because it is about see I
don't now think of myself I'm not some
great humble person
I'm just saying for me to get to where I
was I've reached my goal in iido in
other words I've understood that you
can't keep saying two people must become
one please go pass if I don't really
mean it yeah but I still need to win a
little bit I mean but I don't need to
win anymore because the joy of getting
it the other side now like I have is so
in abundance you know so it's so
wonderful this feeling of
joy that why ever would I want to clash
again but it doesn't make me a guru or
Buddhist mon or spiritual per it just
makes me I've actually
realized that it's not me and him it's
it's where it's him and
him so there two of us and and we'll go
on to do the Kum second kumachi later
and and and I'll be explaining it in
that see it in hairi we'll see it in a
lot of things so you you don't need
anything you what I mean you don't need
anything see that that soft wall
pushing if I want to let it go I'll let
it go if what I've got to decide is do I
need to win no because I don't let it
let him
win that's better and then I do what
Mark
said and I draw him in if you
like so
so so once you get here you you draw
them you start then using your not your
your energy rather than your
willpower so so let's try the
shui and the madori try to realize today
is not a training day it's a searching
day and it's a searching day for you
individually
because if we all done the one wob and
we all had a a five minute teaching spot
there wouldn't be one person who would
look like the other and it's because
you're Guided by what you think up here
you might not realize that it's how you
see
I but we all if if I'm right I'm
thinking we all would like to be closer
to our senses iido